hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from a very exciting
tournament it is the Sharjah Masters
2023 and we have a final round game
between Arjun irrigation
and at the time the game was played they
did not know this but they are playing
for first place so of course they
couldn't know how the other games will
finish well they ended a draw will
someone win who needs a win but
basically whoever won this game will win
the tournament and it was uh very close
there are like uh okay one person won
the tournament and then second place was
shared by eight other people but we're
gonna discuss this after we check out
the game so uh Arjun has the white
pieces and he opens with Ponte E4 and
the Arjun already lost one game in this
tournament whereas uh yakubo have also I
believe lost one game which is very
important for the final standings uh I
will explain why so here Ponte four we
have Ponte E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to C4 with Bishop to C5 and
now not the immediate best move but
first Pawn to C3 we have the Joker piano
uh Knight to F6 we have D3 and uh here
Castles by Aqua we have Castles by
uh Arjun and now point the five point
the D6 and pawn to D5 are the two most
common uh moves here and they have been
played equal amount of time so D5
captures captures and now Rook the E1 so
all very standard stuff going after the
E5 pawn bishop to G4 pinning the Knight
and now Pawn to H3 getting rid of the
bishop Bishop to H5 and now Knight beta
D2 is the most uh common move here but
here we don't have that we have Pawn to
B4 so okay not on move four he plays it
on move 10 uh but it's a very rare even
in this position because I have no idea
why I mean it's such a great move that I
don't know why more people don't play it
uh Bishop back to E7 and now Pawn to B5
and already a very interesting position
occurs because it's not easy for black
to react to this okay it's easy to react
to B5 Knight to A5 is played putting
pressure on the bishop here but now Rook
captures an E5 and now what do you play
here there are so many moves that black
can play here which one is the correct
one so in the game Up characters and F3
was played but I'm just going to show
some other lines that could be preferred
the bishop captures on F3 one of them
being Knight to F6 okay we just bring
the Knight back and you keep your Bishop
on H5 defended another one you could
bring the knights the B6 put pressure on
the bishop and even though it seems like
you're sacrificing a piece you're not
really because after Rook captures an H5
you can play Knight a captress on C4 and
the d-pawn cannot recapture on C4
because the queen on D1 would be hanging
another move you could play is just
capture the bishop and C4 right away and
after Rook captures an H5 now you just
bring the Knight back to B6 and again
the pawn cannot capture because the
queen and D1 will be hanging so those
are some of the options that are
available for black here but in the game
Bishop captures that F3 was played and
now we get this position Queen captures
on F3 and interestingly Bishop captures
an F3 is a new move so as of move 12 we
have a completely new game which is very
exciting as we've
started off with the joker piano Queen
captures an F3 and now Knight back to B6
putting pressure on the bishop here
Bishop to B3 and now Bishop to F6
attacking The Rook but not going back
Arjun is here to uh to put pressure on
black and he wants to fight with Rook to
F5 upon the A6 now getting rid of the
spawn so you can advance the C Pawn as
well captures an E6 with Rook captures
and not just Bishop to C2 Shifting the
bishop over to this diagonal to attack
the black king Rook to E8 a nicely
developing now threatening Rook D1 check
so of course the bishop to E3 stopping
that we have C6 now C6 is a move you
want to play and it gains more control
over the D5 square but it does weaken
the Knight here however noderbeck does
not care about the Knight because how is
white to attack it you can't really
develop the Knight because the C3 Pawn
will hang however that's exactly what
Arjun does he plays Knight to D2 and now
Bishop captures on C3 attacks the rook
and The Rook the B1 was played interest
interestingly Rook captures on F7 is
possible but it's not not all that great
the problem with Rook captures and F7
isn't the bishop captures on A1 it's
actually Queen to D5 and now uh how do
you react to this Knight to E4 of course
you avoid the queen trade and you
offered The Rook on F7 but now not Queen
captures on F7 instead Bishop captures
an A1 Rook captures on B7 Knight
captures on B7 and now Bishop to B3
black even allows his Queen to get
trapped but the point is that after Rook
captures an A2 black just has too much
material for the sacrificed Queen if
Bishop captures Knight captures on D5
and now if you count the material black
has a knight and two Rooks for the queen
and the black is definitely the one to
be preferred here so instead Rook to B1
now putting pressure on that Knight okay
it's defended by the rook and A6 also
but that square is a bit silly for The
Rook to be in uh so here we have Pawn to
G6 the safest way for black to eliminate
any danger is just real captures on E3
uh so that's kind of the point now you
have to capture with the queen because
uh the Knight on D2 is hanging as well
and after the queen captures Knight to
D5 and black has sufficient compensation
for the exchange but in the game G6 was
played attacking The Rook here Rook
captures an F7 and now not Queen to D5
which is uh okay it's not as potent as
in the line that we've shown but it is
the best course of action here for black
uh Rook captures an E3 was played right
away and now it's a bit different okay
you have to decide if you capture with
the queen then The Rook hangs and if you
capture with the pawn then the Knight
hangs that's why Rook captures an E3
appears to be great but it's not uh
Arjun happily plays F captures on E3 and
now after Bishop captures on D2 he plays
Rook the F1 and now he tripled up on the
f file and how do you find a move here
for black how do you stop Rook the f8 of
course you have to play Rook to A8 now
the f8 square is defended but now Queen
to F2 and this is a spectacular move by
Arjun uh forcing the the bishop off of
that D2 square and there's just no good
Square for the bishop Bishop the B4 is
somewhat better however here Bishop the
C3 was played and now feel free to pause
the video and to win the game for Arjun
he has a brilliant move here uh so pause
the video while I give you a couple of
seconds and try to spot this uh maneuver
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on winning this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
Pawn to D4 you close up The Bishop's
diagonal and now there is no defense
against everything that white is
threatening here uh to give you an
example if white plays some sort of a
weird rule let's say plays Knight a to
C4 uh what's White's main threat well
White's main thread is Rook captures on
H7 followed by Queen to F7 Checkmate so
of course you will defend this let's say
queen to f8 not Queen to G3 attacks the
queen and attacks the G6 Pawn so you
have to defend both Queen to E8 and now
Queen to H4 now you are threatening Rook
to h8 and finally after Queen captures
on E3 with check King the H1 and now
Bishop captures on D4 guarding the h8
square doesn't matter Bishop captures on
G6 and black is completely helpless here
if uh Queen to E5 you again have to try
to defend at least uh now you're gonna
play Rook H the F7 and prepare Queen H7
and the only way to cover H7 is Queen
th8 but now of course just Bishop to H7
with check and here Queen captures on H7
we have Queen captures on H7 and this is
now Checkmate so that's one way to do it
another way is Knight the D5 uh which
was played in the game but it also
doesn't help Bishop captures and G6
absolutely crushing by Arjun uh and now
the problem is if you capture here then
just Queen to G3 and how do you defend
against mate if Pawn to G5 okay the
queen guards against that not just Queen
to E5 and there is no defense against
Queen to G7 Checkmate so here after
Bishop to G6 Knight captures and E3 was
played hoping for this final trick Queen
captures an E3 and Bishop captures on D4
to trap the queen but of course Arjun
wasn't uh you know playing any
Immaculate tournament so far to blunder
the the game this way after Knight
captures an E3 he just played Rook to G7
with check and he was in this position
and move 27 that another resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh the only way to deal with this
is to go either King teacher which is
not great Rook to H7 King to G8 and then
Queen to F7 will be Checkmate or to
actually capture The Rook but again it
doesn't help just Queen to F7 with check
King to H6 Queen captures an H7 with
check King to G5 and now Queen to H5
will be Checkmate so like I said they
didn't notice at the time they started
the game but whoever won this game does
win the tournament and uh due to that
here are sorry now that here are the
final standings of the shardock Masters
2023 Arjun arigasi wins the tournament
with six and a half out of nine so it's
not uh it's not a clean sweep it's not a
seven out of nine a nine eight on a nine
a 9.99 it's six and a half out of nine
and you can see that uh there are uh
seven people uh following Arjun uh who
are on six out of nine and you can see
uh down in 10th place
with five and a half out of nine ahead
he won the this game he would also win
the tournament but really incredible
guckish 609 agree with the operating 609
707 609 new Young e609 uh hike martiros
and 609 yeah I mean Tabata by 609 and
Hans neem and six out of nine and again
why I mentioned that both Arjun and
Norberg lost a game prior to their
encounter in round nine is that for
example or gligoriopa in 707 and yuang
Yi and I believe I'm in tabatabai are
all and have all went undefeated in the
tournament but it is Arjun and uh had um
yakuba won the won the game he would
also have won the tournament uh it is
those who who had the greatest fighting
spirit that had a chance and he finally
have won the tournament not those who
who have played Immaculate chess and did
not lose a single game so also something
to consider in your own games it's not
just about not losing the game it's it's
about trying to win it if you try to win
every game you will win the tournament
not if you just don't lose um uh uh you
know any games so I'm also something
that I wanted to share with you guys so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have any other
favorites from the charger Masters do
use hashtag suggestion I wasn't able to
follow all of the games as there were
other events happening in the world as
they are you know constantly there's not
a day that there aren't at least three
big tournaments being played uh so you
know uh you you some some you see some
you don't so always use the use that
hashtag suggestion as it's easier for me
to notice your suggestions uh once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank golfsoftware.com
and an anonymous person for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day